looking back on the five feature films
that you've made you've also worked on a
few television series what year or what
years would you say were the toughest on
you where you thought you know what this
is too hard and I'm going to have to
find something else to do this isn't as
glamorous as I thought it would be or my
wanting to tell a story this is too
emotional for me that's interesting
that's an interesting question I I think
we could almost every time you wrap up a
film there's that period between between
films that you're losing confidence
every day after the release of the first
time you've premiered at a festival and
the confidence level starts to go down
if like how am I going to continue this
what's again I'm now again afore make
another film again oh my god maybe I'm
not you know I I'm a good barista so I
could always go that way but I but then
of course then the film gets released in
theaters and your confidence level goes
back up but then every day after the
release date it slowly goes down so I i
have to say that it's not just one time
or one year it's always post release of
the film that you're most vulnerable
when you're most insecure at least for
me would you say it gets progressively
more emotional with each film that
you've done it depends on the subject
matter okay you know I think that this
film was for me very it was it it took
its toll it wasn't it really was because
of the world that we were working in
and the fact that we were working with
real people off the street sometimes not
our leads but you know there were others
in the film that we're actually coming
from that world m and the hardship that
they've had to deal with in poverty and
you know that this this film took its
toll
you